okay hello everybody
so Matthew and I we are starting our
second conversation further for our
YouTube channel and we thought that this
time we could talk about the the problem
of self reference and also the the idea
of how symbolism works as a series of
embedded patterns one in in each other
like a kind of fractal structure where
the larger structure repeats itself in
the in the smaller structure and how
those two questions the question of self
referentiality and the question of
patterns embedding themselves as
replicating themselves in embedded
structures how they're related and and
to be honest we're a bit we're a bit
nervous to talk about this because the
Col question of self reference and the
question of things that refer to
themselves is is the kind of subject
which just when you try to talk about it
and when you even when you try to think
about it turns your brain into a kind of
mush where all of a sudden you you can't
see clearly because of the the problem
of of something trying to look at itself
but it's a really important aspect of
symbolism and it's an important aspect
of what's happening right now in the
world because this this problem of self
reference is popping up more and more
even in science and and in culture and
so so it's important to talk about it so
maybe the first thing we can we can
start with is the the first the the
question of how we mentioned this in our
last discussion a little bit the problem
of science as it stands right now is
that it approaches the world as if the
theory with which is looking at the
world is not part of the universe but it
has to be part of the universe because I
mean the universe is is is is everything
and so the theory has to somehow be part
of the universe but the question is how
can it be at the same time part of the
universe while being the thing that's
looking at the universe trying to
understand it and I think that
consciousness really is the key to this
you know and and I think that all the
reason why
like Jordan Peterson and even people
like Sam Harris they're trying to talk
about consciousness and sometimes they
struggle to to fit all those things
together there's an intuition that
consciousness is the key because
consciousness is you know is a
self-referential phenomena it is the
capacity that we have to to kind of in
one way stand above ourselves and look
at ourselves but at the same time this
capacity to look at ourselves as part of
ourselves as well and so so there's this
there is it's as if the origin of
consciousness is a self referential loop
which then moves out into the world and
then becomes a coherent a coherent let's
say structure of representation but it
starts in this in this necessarily self
referential loop and that seems to be
that's that self referential loop at the
beginning of reason or at the beginning
of logic and their beginning of a
structured world seems to be the thing
that that that science or that you know
kind of skeptic type people want to
avoid they want to avoid the the
inevitability of that of that that
problem of a self referential loop at
the beginning of things yeah I would say
this consciousness or I should say
self-awareness or something like that
maybe not just consciousness is when you
begin to include yourself in your in
your model of the universe so we make
models of the universe that's what we do
on a regular basis I would say you
become a little bit more self-aware when
you when you become aware of the the
fact that there is a theory and there
are facts or there's language and
there's facts and we when you when you
get out of the system and you see this
that's one kind of awareness but then I
think there's another level of awareness
where you realize that or you identify
with not the language
not the theory but the mediator between
the theory and the fact it's hard to
explain but yeah it's one of the things
that seems to be bringing this up and
and and this has been interesting for me
to watch and I see it with especially
with what Jordan Peterson has been
talking about is it is using biology and
using Darwinism as a way to show the
problem of this self referential loop
because when when using using biology
and neural neuro psychology and and
Darwinism you have to to realize that
our models of the universe the way we
look at the universe has to be part of
that the process which made us human it
has to be a a product of of evolution or
a product of the of the of the manner in
which we think or the manner in which we
look at the world you can't it's like
when you you used biology or Darwinism
as a as a basis for the science all of a
sudden you know even physics has to be a
product of evolution even mathematics
has to be a product of evolution and so
there is enough it seemed like there's
enough self referential capacity for
self reference to be able to give
something which looks like the
traditional yeah looks like the
hierarchy of values that we find in the
traditional worldview and it's so that's
that's been interesting for me to watch
because you know the way Jordan has been
presenting this hierarchy of values
isn't exactly the same ontological
hierarchy that we find in a traditional
representation but there's enough
correlation between the two to be able
to say okay well you know in the Bible
and when we talk about God in heaven and
when we talk about angels and when we
talk about Earth that's what we're
talking about we're talking about a
similar type of structure which which
which is the the type of dominance
hierarchy as he uses as Jordan uses that
you have in Darwin
and that and that that that dot that
dominance hierarchy where let's say our
our theory of physics would be in that
dominance hierarchy and would be let's
say one of the major tool that human
beings have has developed to interact
with the world like that type of self
referential capacity is what gives that
the possibility of that hierarchy of
values like I said like we're saying and
this is stuff is really difficult to
think about and difficult to talk about
but it seems like that what's funny is
is I'm sorry I was just gonna say when
you think in within traditional terms as
in traditional cosmology it's not a
complicated subject at all yeah it's the
most obvious thing but when you try to
think of it with the lens of of science
materialism then it becomes a really
complicated thing because you're trying
to let's say find some kind of agreement
between the traditional cosmology and
the materialistic one so that's that's
what's difficult it's trying to
reconcile those two perspectives really
because when you when you begin to think
in a traditional way it's not a
complicated thing at all the idea of
self reference and the notion that the
universe is a fractal is one of the
first things that you you encounter yeah
because it's a natural it's a natural
thing I mean symbols are usually
fractals okay so maybe instead of trying
because maybe instead of trying to break
through the conversation at least expose
the problem but I think maybe by giving
a few examples from the traditional
point of view giving a few examples from
the Bible might be the best way for
people to see how that how this works
and how it elucidates not only the Bible
but it also elucidates our experience of
the world so I don't know if you want to
talk about I know that in your book
one of the major structures that you
elucidate is the the relationship
between the cosmic shape and the shape
of the human being and how those two are
images of each other so maybe you can go
a little bit into that knowing people we
people will be able to get all the
details when your book is out but maybe
you can explain a little bit of how that
that would work yeah okay I can try it's
a difficult thing because because almost
all of the concepts that we use today
are not the same as as the ancient
concept so it's always difficult to talk
about symbolism I'm still gonna try but
it's always difficult because we always
assume that we know the meaning of words
yeah and we do but it's not that it just
happens to be not the same as the
ancient meaning so oh when I talk about
these things I'll try to if I realize
that the words that I'm using I'm using
them in an ancient way then I'll try or
if you see that I'm doing that maybe you
wanna tell me you can do is at least
aesthetically let's say like these in
terms of the actual terms of the story
you can show the parallels in the terms
of the story so that people can see that
there's clearly a relationship of
structure and then once you show that
then after that we can we can try to
explain the let's say the deeper
meanings of those concepts but at least
people don't even see the actual pattern
like they they struggle to even see the
pattern so at least once they see the
pattern we can then try to explain it
okay so the most the easiest to
understand I would say the the microcosm
that's easiest to understand is the one
you just said it which relates an
individual to the entire universe and
when when when we say that we're talking
about the cosmos that's in the Bible
okay not not the materialistic one that
we have today the mechanistic one we're
talking about the universe as described
in traditional cosmology where you have
heaven and earth and you have a mediator
which is men when you look at it like
that and when you understand the idea
that earth means
factual reality physical reality and
heaven means ideas or theories or
principles that are not manifest or that
are not concrete or practical something
like that then you can start to see that
individual human beings their shape is
the same as that that cosmos then it's
actually pretty obvious it's we no
longer see it that much because we no
longer see the cosmos in the in the
ancient way so we're not used to seeing
those connections but when you do then
you realize that an individual has a
mind and a body it's it's the mind is
the equivalent of heaven and the body is
the equivalent of Earth and in the Bible
it's pretty clear when when God creates
Adam and by the way Adam means humanity
so I think that's important to mention
because that's just another example of
different that's a Bible interpret the
different scales because the word Adam
means an individual a human and then
it's the name of an individual but it
also means humanity Laura so Freddie
means it's yes yeah so if you manage
something like that so whenever there's
in the Bible it talks about Adam in the
story of Adam and Eve it's talking about
humanity at large yeah and it's also
talking about an individual so that's
something to be aware of it's just an
example of somebody that exact that that
that example you gave itself as an
example of how it's it's using a
particular image a particular let's say
story of a man to be the microcosm of
all of humanity and so even in the story
itself it's built to be that way yeah
and then the the shape of of man let's
say at the beginning of Genesis when God
creates having an earth it says God God
created heaven and earth the the the
earth was chaos and void and the Spirit
of God was above the waters and so you
have this idea of spirit and spirit is
wind or
rath it's alright yes that that's also
important to say yeah when it says the
word spirit
it means wind it also means breath
because breath is wind right there's no
difference it's like what you said in
the last video it's not a metaphor
breath is wind red is actually wind and
so and the only difference which is
important oh that's another example of a
word that that we have to sort of
redefine the word spirit breath sold all
those words they refer to the breath it
means breath and it right away if you
understand that you can see the
relationship with heaven and in the
story it says God formed Adam from the
dust of the earth and blew into his
nostrils the breath of life so right
there you can see that it's all about
joining heaven and earth yeah so the
breath comes from heaven and the he
raises some earth in the nest man yeah
that man is made from that Union and
it's exactly when you talk about the
mediator then it shows exactly that that
man is the mediator because in the
beginning these two things are
completely separate you have you have
heaven and spirit and breath and wind
above and you have this chaotic formless
earth at the bottom and those two things
don't let's say they don't touch each
other they're there they're separate and
then then there's the creation of the
different the different strata the
strats of of creation the heavens and
then the grass and then it comes closer
and closer and closer until you reach
the human being and then the human being
has the heaven enter into the earth and
joins with the earth so that quite you
know explicitly in the story man is that
is a microcosm of having an earth but
also the mediator because he joins them
together
he's not just a representation of that
separation but actually a representation
of that union and then within man
there's another microcosm which is the
separation of man and woman which
represents again heaven and earth which
are separated you know man being heaven
and
being earth but then you United at the
same time so like and then that keeps
you know it's like these microcosm keep
embed keep embedding themselves into
each other to create this fractal
structure that we're talking about the
Bible is just full of those those
fractal like structures oh yeah I just
want to say something about also again
the concept of breath maybe just talk a
little bit about that because it's it's
also important to understand the
connection if you want to think in that
way where the breath is related to the
mind the breath is related to the
intellect that's something we don't
really we don't really see things like
that anymore but it's a pretty obvious
thing actually that your breath and your
intellect are related because if you
stop breathing I mean I wouldn't I
wouldn't recommend this but stop
breathing for 20 minutes you lose
consciousness
[Laughter]
so there's a clear connection between
breathlessness and intellect and things
of that we're kids people would play
that game where they would choke someone
that's a bad game but people would like
choke someone until they actually passed
out it was like it was like a very
disturbing game that people played but
there's also the idea I just wanted to
say that the idea is there is an obvious
connection between heaven air wind
breath intellect that we don't
necessarily see anymore but when you
read the Bible you have to understand
these connections in order to understand
most of the stories in the Bible yeah
and also the one of the connections
between breath and intellect is through
the idea of word or logos because yeah
because speaking is the manifestation of
intellect and speaking is words are
pushed by this breath the breath pushes
out the sounds and so there's an others
a definite there's an obvious
relationship between the manifestation
of intellect and and and breath and you
see that in the story of Genesis itself
again
God speaks in order to separate the
things of the world God speaks the so
you have to kind of almost see this
image of this breath that is above of
above the earth and then it becomes the
vehicle for God's intellect to to
manifest itself and create the world and
importantly the first words that come
out of God's mouth are let there be
light
okay so it says the the breath of God or
the Spirit of God or the wind of God
hovered over the waters and then God
said with that breath let there be light
so the light is in ancient cosmology is
is is meaning you know you represent the
intellect the meaning the principle the
idea so that which gives meaning to
other things that which defines things
it's it's the logos it's the word its
its reason its logic things like things
of that nature
yes although there's this this verse in
that I think it's Christ who actually
says that who says the eye is the light
of the of the body and I remember you
always read more boring me these
annoying materialists who who just see
that as a kind of you know a kind of
misunderstanding of science you know
once again failing to realize that
people were just weren't materialist
about 2,000 years ago to see it rather
in that sense that when you you take
into account the consciousness in the
scope of how the world exists if you
take into account the fact that
consciousness mediates between you know
the this the potentiality of the world
and then the the capacity for that world
to have sense and have meaning then the
idea that the eye is the light is the
lamp of the world makes app makes total
sense because the when because light is
not is light is meaning in ancient
cosmology like to look at something is
to is to separate it from the
potentiality and to define it to define
it yeah to make it into a concrete not
to make it but to participate in its in
its appearance as a
crude thing right because I mean you
could you could separate it into into
atoms and atoms and neutron whatever and
subatomic particles but we don't we it's
focused it's coherent and that the human
consciousness is part of that emergent
phenomena yeah so I think that's another
yet another example of how we have to
redefine words because the definition of
light today is again a materialistic
definition but in the past in aichi
cosmology it was not the same at all so
it's it's extremely important to relight
in a traditional cosmology and in
reading the light once again it's not
hard to do that because you all you have
to do is to understand it in terms of
phenomenology in terms of of how the
phenomena how we interact with that
phenomena I mean light is that which
makes things visible like yeah that's
what light is it isn't in a human
experience light is not a wave or a
particle or or like you know the the
this the constant you know that the
speed of light is is it not all those
things are not important in the way we
we interact with it in in our in our
everyday life light is that which makes
things appear like it makes them visible
it turns like if you walk into a dark
room in the in the absolute darkness
you're gonna bump into things you're
gonna you're gonna not know what's there
you could die you could fall into a hole
anything could happen but when the light
goes on then all of a sudden things
become clearer and things become
separate things become unified and in
your find well defined and well defined
in your experience that's why also why
like you said that's why the first thing
God creates is light because it's that
concise possible animus with speaking
with word like yeah and so yeah I was
thinking an example again of that man is
a mediator between heaven and earth so
when God asked Adam to name the animals
that's a perfect example of being a
mediator between heaven and earth
because then what Adam has to do is take
an abstract idea that he has and then
bring it into concrete manifestation so
he names the animals according to
certain ideas that he has that's the
idea so he's like in but he's seeing his
ideas embodied in certain beings in the
world and he's giving that identity to
those animals
yes and it's important to see it's
because this is one thing that people
are are are struggle with is that the
idea when you say like he he has these
ideas about the world people right away
thing oh it's relativity subjectivity
it's like no that's not it because it's
because he is a mediator between heaven
and earth the the the connection between
the idea and the phenomena that is
appearing before him is is a unitive and
a real thing like it's it's it's
actually the thing itself like it's the
capacity to participate in the thing
itself as well it's not just like he has
this he has a fantasy or or whatever
right it's not just a whim right right
it's based on it's based on his reason
is based on his intellect so he is the
point where that those phenomenon are
that he is encountering actually
connects with their meaning like it's
not it's not in a way like he doesn't
have a choice like the way we think of
choice today in naming the animals he
sees the light of his I like that and
his word come together and participate
in the being of that of that thing
that's in front of in front of him it's
hard to think about in such kind of
direct way because we you know our
experience of the world is is more is
more that's a deluded let's say but we
have to understand that that the story
in Genesis Adam represents man as such
in a in a kind of pure let's say on you
know untrammeled way let's say before
the fall we would say in Christian terms
so yeah and and it's related the idea of
the fall is related to losing that
capacity yeah so
losing the capacity of correctly naming
the animals or correctly perceiving the
world according to its spiritual meaning
so yes so we we can't imagine what that
means obviously that's the image is
there in the in the story because when
Adam and Eve are chased from the garden
the consequences or that are that God
gives to Adam and Eve are that like the
idea that that Adam will have to work
the the ground and the idea also that
there will be thorns is this notion that
it's as if the earth is revolting
against Adams mediating meeting
principle or else he's losing its
capacity to be a natural mediator and so
he has to to supplement that that that
state with with effort like yes he has
to he has to be careful because the the
the the potential the the world deal
it's a the the created role becomes
dangerous for him and so he has to fight
it off in some ways and yes to the hold
it at bay so that he can continue to
play that role as mediator yeah well
yeah the idea is that well this this
will give us other examples of microcosm
in the Bible as well the idea is that
after the fall humanity has to to
correct or fix certain things
artificially in order for the meaning
and the fact to match correctly so so
for example there's a lot of examples
about it like you said working the
ground in the garden Adam naturally gets
food but this is see now we if we want
to talk about these things it we have to
I can't define a lot of terms but that's
another example of being a mediator
between heaven and earth humans eat food
okay food comes from the earth yeah we
eat it it becomes our body so it's kind
of a reproduction of what I said before
when God created Adam he come in from
the earth well each time we eat we're
doing that in a way
we're gathering the earth into ourselves
to ourself in a way that works because
we can't just eat soil obviously we have
to arrange the matter in a way that will
it will be able to host our intellect
our patterns are our ideas so you eat
certain foods that your that can host
your mind that's the idea of your spirit
mm-hmm so not all matter can do that and
the idea is that in the garden there was
a natural way in which this happened
with with the fruits of a tree and then
once we lost that then we had to fix
things so that they could host meaning
so the the greatest example of that is
the idea of building the temple mm-hmm
so why do they have to build a temple
because they have to artificially join
heaven and earth it doesn't happen in a
natural way anymore
because of the fall so now we have to
arrange the facts in a way artificially
so that they're able to host the
identity the breath the Spirit of God
mm-hmm it becomes like a body for God
similarly when we eat food ourselves we
have to arrange it we cook it you fix it
we don't eat raw meat for example
because if we do we might get sick
getting sick means that it doesn't host
our spirit yeah
correctly that's what it means so when
you when you cook food and you arrange
it in a way that it becomes edible it's
it's it's this it's kind of the same
thing as building a temple it means
you're arranging certain facts so that
they can artificially host your your
spirit your mind yeah and there's like a
and there's a grand pattern in the Bible
like the grand story which is which kind
of embeds all these things together and
this idea is that you have this this
garden at the beginning and then the
fall we move away from the garden and we
keep moving further and further away
from the garden and as we move further
and further away from the garden we have
to supplement that fall with artificial
like
clothing than agriculture then cities
etc etc and in a way it's like this
straight it's like I'm moving away from
the garden but it's also a way it's also
a way to preserve the possibility of
being mediator and having a nurse yeah
so then at the very very end of the
whole story this idea of this New
Jerusalem that comes down from heaven we
have this idea of that the final let's
say manifestation of this whole big big
big big big pattern is a giant city
right so in a perfect city let's say
which which is the full supplemental
thing with in the center the garden with
the tree in the middle in the garden in
the middle and then the whole center so
it's like there's this whole process
whole story in the Bible and at the end
there's an image of the final result of
it which kind of Rhian capsule AIT's the
whole story let's say so it's like
that's also an example of how these
patterns like they they embed themselves
in each other and then finally there's
this final image of this this giant
pattern of how the world exists yeah so
here's another example of a microcosm
which which is related to what what we
just said so the idea of nakedness in
the Bible the idea of being either naked
or dressed is also an example of a
concept that applies two different
scales of reality so when we say in the
Bible when it says naked it's a very
deep concept but we can talk about it a
little bit I don't think I'll be able to
reach all of the implications here but
the idea is naked means natural mm-hmm
that's what it means but that has a
whole lot of implications in the Bible
so things are are natural when you say
they're naked it means they're in their
natural state so but if you think about
this ancient cosmology what was the most
natural state is the first day of
creation before creation is this world
covered with water okay that's what make
the most natural thing in that cosmology
is the flooded world this is a little
bit strange we're not
- thinking oh yeah that's a no it's
tough for people to get it but it's
important it's really important yeah
it's important because with that idea
you can understand a lot of the
symbolism in the Bible so the most
natural state is this state of cyclical
reality which is the first day of
creation where everything is fluid and
that goes with the idea that things
haven't been differentiated yet right
everything is connected in a fluid way
things aren't distinct so when it talks
about being naked it's related to that
idea okay so this is why also in the in
the story of Adam and Eve it says the
snake was the most shrewd beast of the
field okay but the word fruit it means
naked okay but then when you understand
the idea that naked in the Bible refers
to the most natural state then you can
understand why the snake is naked okay
because this snake is like this fluid
for being is like the water at the
beginning naked means natural it's like
the most primitive state now there's
nothing wrong with the nakedness until
the fall
yeah because things were naturally
mediated correctly that's the idea of
the fall and then when there's the fall
it means Adam and Eve tried to eat
something they couldn't handle that
means they tried to take facts into
their include facts that they didn't
know what to name how to explain with
their theories that's really what it
means so when you eat something that you
can't handle it that's that's the
miniature version of a bigger picture
where you see things that you don't know
how to name you can't name you can't
identify then that has something to do
why when Jordan Peterson is always
talking about this it is this kind of
entry into chaos where you know you if
you face something was disrupts you what
you know it's like and all of a sudden
you you don't know like he talks often
about this idea that you know you find
out that your spouse has been cheating
on you for 10 years and so that that
that that like that hitting of a fact or
something that you can't
ándale you know throws your whole world
up into upheaval and it's like
everything is on the verge of falling
apart so then you have to you have to
work at putting things together like
after it's like it needs the work to
bring things back to fix things yeah
exactly you have to fix things make them
fit your mind again make them fit your
plans let's say you have plans yeah
something happens that isn't part of
your planning you don't know what to do
with it it it makes you wander yeah it
could be anything your car breaks yeah
you're driving - you're driving on a
trip your car breaks down all of a
sudden you have to change your plans if
you don't you're going to wander and be
into absolute chaos you have to work to
rearrange things so that it can fit with
you what you're trying to do or that it
can lead to something that's that that
isn't just absolute you know nothingness
right yeah so the idea the idea of
nakedness and rest it has a cosmic
meaning it has an individual meaning so
the idea is that things are either in a
natural state or they're artificially
fixed to make them work to make them to
make your theorists match the facts so
this happens at the individual level I
mean you have an idea have a plan but
maybe your body your passions or
whatever don't cooperate yeah so you
want to do something but let's say
you're lazy that's your body telling you
no sorry I don't agree with your plans
I'm not gonna follow along so you have
to force artificially force yourself to
do certain things so that that's what it
means to be dressed in the Bible and and
clothing itself is an example of that so
again it's not it's not about having
metaphors the idea of clothing that's
what clothing is for open its its to
correct your passions okay it's to give
your your head your mind your your your
things that have a purpose to give them
dominance over your body yeah yeah you
because you know you're you're coal
so that's an example let's say you're
cold and so you wear clothing so that
you're not cold also you if let's say
you you everybody was naked on all of a
sudden you know your desires would be
there'll be problem would be always be a
way awakened and so to clothe them is to
be able to manage those desires so that
you can do something else besides being
completely taken over by those by those
by those types of thoughts and such yeah
so so here's another example of again of
seeing it as as a different skills so
you can say for example so clothing when
we when it talks about dressing in the
Bible another example if you look at it
a slightly bigger scale so at a social
scale let's say at the scale of a
society well you have the same idea you
have some individuals that are the head
of that society they're the leaders they
make the laws they they make sure that
the laws are followed and then you have
a population so the idea is in order
dressing dressing this this society
would mean making laws and forcing
people to follow the laws like jail for
example is an example of clothing but
not at the scale of the individual at
the scale of the society so you make
some laws people don't naturally follow
those laws necessarily so what do you
have to do you have to fix the
population so that it follows your laws
so when you put people in jail that is
the equivalent of dressing yourself
right extreme version of dressing yeah
well it's it's yeah it's only extreme
because it's a bigger social level right
you look at it at a bigger scale it
always it's always more extreme I mean
if we if we if we were at the scale of
our body parts and we saw that what
dressing did we would probably find it
extreme but we're not here's an example
here's another example also of different
scales so these are these are very
to get its ugly but we're gonna try
anyway so at the individual scale we're
talking about eating before taking in
matter into your body so that same
concept exists at a slightly bigger
scale which is the scale of a society a
society or a civilization eats but what
does it eat it eats people
it looks pretty see to say it doesn't
literally eat people with the deed but
the the society is a being and it
integrates more individuals so when
somebody is integrated into the society
that's a larger scale version of an
individual eating food and that's very
important in the Bible and the way the
way it eats people let's say to not make
it sound crazy is is is that it
integrates their work it integrates
their businesses it integrates their tax
money it integrates you know their their
children and and and and it also makes
them part it makes those an identity
yeah and give them exactly this a lock
them participate in the identity of the
city or of the nation or of the the
group whatever that is it gives them it
says you're part of this group and that
and your exchange like your trade for
that that you give me your your strength
your work your your your services so
that we all participate in this unity
like this you this unity so yeah it's a
perfect example of that appearing at
different scales and it's actually
exactly the same thing that we do when
we eat food because food is is matter we
eat it it becomes our body what does
that mean become our body it means now
you will follow the laws of this this
being the laws so my hand used to be a
sandwich it's it's not a metaphor and he
I hate a sandwich it became my flesh now
this flesh follows the instructions of
my head it follows the laws it follows
my identity it doesn't follow it only
it's its natural state anymore
it's it again there's no metaphor in
there at all so at a biggest scale
individuals are
by a society it means they're integrated
into that body advocate and on the
condition that they follow the the laws
of that society they follow the rules so
that's like the sandwich becoming my
flesh and following the laws of my head
that it's it's it's just that a slightly
bigger step so what does it mean to
dress the body at the individual level
it means put clothing on but it also
means to force my body to some degree to
do certain things that it naturally
wouldn't yeah because like I said you
could be either be lazy or you could
have too much energy or something like
that you have to restrain yourself so in
a society same thing there are certain
rules that are there just to restrain
artificially make the body coherent yeah
that's right so I I think that if we try
to come back slightly to our beginning
point which was talking a little bit
about let's say the way the place where
thought is today and and and like the
questions that scientists and and those
types of thinkers are asking themselves
I think that we can come to this notion
of this concept of emergence which has
been kind of a buzzword for the past you
know 10 years or whatever I don't
remember exactly when it started but its
idea that that these these pattern
beings appear at different levels of a
manifestation you know like an
individualist city than the cosmos and
planetary systems and all that that in
fact and the struggle scientist types
have in in accounting for that for that
that jump in different levels of
manifestation well I think that we can
we can say that the key is consciousness
like it has to be consciousness and that
that taking into account the the self
the self referential loop at the
beginning right this the the self
referential loop of self-awareness and
consciousness is and int in including
the fact that we are the ones looking at
these phenomena into the system is going
to be the only way to get out of this
dilemma one of the things that I want to
do in these YouTube channels and
hopefully we can do it together as well
is maybe sometimes take
particular stories or particular you
know laws in the Bible and then just
show people how that those that fractal
structure of symbolism how these
patterns embed themselves in each other
and how really almost all like let's say
all of them even are just a repetition
of that very first story in in Genesis
of the creation story where heaven and
earth are separate and then United in in
the human being that that all the
stories are just kind of these
repetitions of the same pattern in
different ways at different scales with
different variables but just kind of
repeat this and and fit into each other
yeah yeah the story of the Garden of
Eden is the is the ultimate pattern of
everything it's it's meant to explain
everything well there isn't the solution
to the products plane the problem that
we're in I would say the solution is
probably innocence Christ I think that
solution is the story it's not in this
story yeah we'll get there at some point
start talking about how the story of
Christ is like almost is this answer
like constant answer to the to the the
the dilemmas and the the openings that
are proposed in in in in in Genesis how
how his story kind of unites everything
together let's say so but the way we
need to kind of move through it slowly
so that people can can understand it
when we talk about it okay well I think
that I think that we've got some good
stuff and so this is what we wrote this
is what we have until until your book is
ready and people can dive into it in
more detail and so yeah so we'll talk
more and see if there's other no
examples that we can that we can bring
up and maybe go into certain stories
together one of the things I like to do
maybe in the future with you is as I
wanted to talk about the story of Tamar
which you talked about in in the video
with Jordan Peterson because I think a
lot of people they would I think that
that if that story is really difficult
but I think that if you can understand
that story you can understand a lot of
things that are happening right now in
our society so it'd be interesting to
talk about yeah it's uh it's it's often
a question of we redefining the terms
again that's right
difficult to talk about symbolism today
things that used to be absolutely
obvious in the best IV kind of extremely
difficult to understand today because we
don't have the same perspective at all
yeah so that's all luckily we still have
our everyday experience which we can use
as a as a base for for understanding
symbolism so so hopefully we can get
people to to get back into their into
the more primordial experience of their
body and everyday life which is the
which is a good way to start at least
yeah all right so so what everybody will
see you very soon
well bye if you enjoyed this content and
our exploration of symbolism get
involved I love to read your comments in
the comment section below please go
ahead and share this on social media to
all your friends and also please
consider supporting us financially on
patreon you'll find a link to the
patreon page in the description below